d'abord je voudrais m'adresser à madame
el fassi de 0 à 7 france non c'est vrai
vous n'existez pas en guyane mais
j'aurais souhaité savoir si vous êtes en
lien avec une association
en guyane justement pour présenter des
actions pour la réduction des déchets je
pense que vous connaissez la
problématique chez nous et puis je vais
m'adresser également à monsieur le comte
je ferai une petite parenthèse qui n'a
rien à voir avec la gestion des déchets
avant d'arriver à ma question monsieur
le comte je sais que l'adn de votre
structure est de concilier équilibres
naturels et activités humaines et de
proposer des pistes pour adapter notre
planète au changement climatique et les
atténuer pourtant j'ai la fâcheuse
impression qu'en guyane
france nature environnement ses vertus
surtout à annihiler tout projet de
développement je veux parler du projet
de montagne d'or et plus récemment la
centale du larivot aujourd'hui à
l'intéressement qui sont faits les chefs
d'entreprises qui sont en difficulté qui
ont investi dans des camions et
aujourd'hui ben c'est l'arrêt c'est
l'arrêt de du projet donc voilà je
voulais faire cette petite parenthèse
avec vous alors ma question sur en
matière de gestion des déchets guyane
nature environnement et bien informé des
difficultés des communes enclavées vous
le savez en guyane il faut considérer
2-2 de guyane deux départements puisque
vous avez les communes de l'intérieur
qui qui souffre justement par rapport
aux déchets puisqu'il n'y a pas de route
il n'y a pas de décharge il ya de
grosses difficultés des communes qui
sont reliés par des fleuves et comme je
parlais de des villages comme twin qui
hélas est hanté combattent à voilà les
habitants quand on leur rend visite ils
disent on est français mais voilà on a
des déchets on sait pas quoi en faire
personne ne les gère et donc je voudrais
savoir comment est-ce qu'on peut compter
d'abord sur votre expertise et que
peuvent faire guyane nature
environnement qui dépend de votre
association nous pensons nous
aujourd'hui que les collectivités
locales 1 va trouver dans les
associations un partenaire tout à fait
efficace pour l'éducation à
l'environnement dans la pratique ça se
fait pas tant que ça et nous le
regrettons parce que
alors est ce que c'est parce que souvent
des associations sont des il faut le
reconnaître un de contestation de
certains projets
à l'instar de l'exemple que vous avez
cités en guyane
c'est possible mais en réalité
nous devrions pas chercher une bonne
intelligence pour l'intérêt collectif
donc je sais que là où ça s'est fait ça
a été extrêmement positifs extrêmement
constructif ça s'est fait dans certaines
communes d'outre-mer je suis pas capable
de vous donner les exemples précis là
tout de suite mais je sais que ça
existait et quand ça existe et en
général ça a été extrêmement extrêmement
positif donc je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'on me voit en tout
cas nous nous sommes très ouverts à ces
collaborations entre collectivités et
associations pour développer la
sensibilisation